I did once go into print calling John
staliano the Woody Allen of porn
[Music]
I teach a huge variety of courses
ranging a wide across going media
history in theory but the only course
anybody ever remembers before is the
porn class with every technological
advance we have seen a greater
democratization of culture generally but
certainly of sexually explicit
expression I mean this is from the
printing press and medieval manuscripts
this is from photography film video the
internet each time it has allowed more
and more people and of different genders
and different classes to be able to have
access to sexually explicit expression
and that's the great fear that's
represented by the internet and it's
just the you know most recent wave of
hysteria that's around the
democratization of sexual expression
when judge Potter Stewart said I can't
define pornography but I know it when I
see it that's the attitude that a lot of
people have they don't in fact think
it's important to define pornography to
discover what it really is they think
they already know it and so they can go
ahead and legislature it regulate it
debate it because we don't even have to
talk about it it's a given that there is
something very very wrong with it that
it's not just sexually explicit
representation it is obscene that is it
has no First Amendment protection and
can be banned
[Music]
whenever I start to teach the Miller
test for determining what material is
obscene in my classroom the students
have such an enormous ly difficult time
getting their minds around most of the
terminology in the Miller test I mean
the first part of it the two that speak
to community standards you know whether
a reasonable person in the community
would find the material to be appealing
to present interests or the second
community standard whether a reasonable
person in the community would find the
material to be patently offensive and
then the third which is a national
standard onion does the material have
any serious literary artistic political
or scientific value and so my students
immediately start going what's variant
you know and you try to explain well
it's a bad relation to sexual materials
it's a morbid interest in sexual
materials and they go well what's that
you know and then they go well what's
patently offensive you know and isn't
porn supposed to offend doesn't it have
a lot of its challenge to sexual and
moral taboos and also isn't it supposed
to use lewdness and lewd humor to
challenge political authority so they
just cannot even get their minds around
material that could be attacked for
vaguely appealing to a morbid interest
in sex what would that be your interest
in sex but not my interest in sex and
you know what's patently offensive when
porn it's supposed to be patently
offensive I've come to realize that so
much of what people object to in
pornographic materials is not that it
challenges their moral values their
religious values but that they just
think it's in bad taste and they think
that
whatever taste they have is of course
superior taste john staliano has been
indicted on several accounts of
obscenity these are federal charges and
he's been charged not for his own work
not the work that he has done his own
directed pieces which are you know
highly awarded and regarded work in in
the adult film industry but he has been
charged for videos and a trailer that
his company has distributed John
staliano is like a studio head you know
he has his own brand evil angel but he
also has his studio the evil empire I
was surprised at the indited videos milk
[ __ ] storm squirters - target
practice and fetish fanatic 5 they are
all done by some of the top people in
the industry and these are people that
John chose to do these videos and for
one thing just I was just surprised
because they are I mean since when did
women exchanging bodily fluids and a
little light bondage become the most
obscene thing in the land but I think
that what the prosecution wants to try
to do I mean they are gross you know
there are deliberately gross they're
also quite playful and I think that they
want the jury to be able to look at this
and say oh my god this is this is gross
this is offensive this is you know awful
and of course we know that juries don't
often say what a reasonable person in
the community might think but they're
really saying what they think what their
reaction is to this so I think one of
the things that would be interesting and
I'm not
sure how this could be done but to be
able to give the bad taste the gross
Ness
of these videos historical context you
know where yeah these videos are meant
to gross you out you know they're meant
to make you think about you know what's
acceptable in our culture and to really
challenge those boundaries about what's
acceptable to you I did once go into
print calling John staliano the Woody
Allen of porn and I believe I said after
that John staliano did for anal
fetishism what Woody Allen did for
neurosis because I really do think of
him that way I mean especially in his
but man character you know where he's
kind of hapless and you know never
achieves his desires I'm endless desires
to really be able to find the perfect
butt
[Music]